hey guys Pete here today I'm gonna dive
into my Reebok for mr. robot season one
this is my third time going through the
season but the first time after the
conclusion of season two even though I
know what happens beyond what I'm
watching my plan is to look at each
episode independently and not spoil
future events I'll point out what stands
out to me this time through but it
should be fine to watch for both people
who've already seen the episodes and
those who are brand new to mr. robot
I'll talk more at the end about specific
reasons I fell in love with the show but
I'm gonna do a quick overview right now
before I get started mr. robot is Laird
and this leads to a lot of fun
speculating in between episodes each
week I think what's compelling about the
show actually develops over time but in
the beginning it's all about Elliott in
this pilot episode especially through
building the events within Elliott's
head and then providing clues that he
isn't the most reliable narrator sets
the wheels in our head spinning and the
whole thing kind of builds from there
also by all accounts the show
establishes a look a sound and the
acting is top-notch across the board the
pilot has a few minor problems that I'll
get to later but overall the vision of
the series is delivered even though
we're not exactly sure where things are
headed all right so I'm gonna jump into
the recap now I'm gonna try to keep it
as brief as possible but a ton of
information comes up here so I am going
to point out the characters the
important events and we'll go from there
and dig deep after this heart so in the
very beginning we get a formal
introduction as us as an imaginary
friend it starts out with hello friend
and Elliott talking about the idea of
creating this we are in a way his
imaginary friend and this will become
more clear later as he confides in us
about what's going on and his struggle
in understanding everything and that's
going on in front of his eyes so we get
a mention here of the 1% of the 1% who
Elliott now believes
is following him before the creator Sam
SML dives directly into these
conspiracies and sort of like this
hacktivists collective mindset we start
out with seeing Elliot and realise that
he's socially awkward a bit anxious
probably clinically depressed and he's a
cyber security engineer by day but also
has a life at night where he's basically
a vigilante hacker we learned this at
first when we meet Ron Elliot confronts
Ron at his coffee shop and we see that
he actually has a bit of a connection
with him before the downfall this is
kind of interesting and we learned that
Elliot's father was the only person he
could talk to but he died he points out
that this happened in relation to the
place where his father worked and that
his father's gone but the corporation
still exists I know he doesn't really
care about money he's not hacking his
own personal gain he's kind of a Robin
Hood in a way and he's there because ron
has some ties to child pornography and
he eventually sets him up and turns him
into the police after that we see him
being paranoid on the train and we run
into the first sighting of Christian
Slater's character then we meet two
characters Angela and Gideon at where he
works which is a place called all safe
we get a better look into how strange
and uncomfortable Elliot can be when we
see him standing outside Angela's
birthday party we know he's known her
for his entire life but he still can't
force himself to go into the door and
hang out with her on her birthday even
though she wants him to be there we meet
Krista Elliot's therapist she mentioned
something about how he got there and
about controlling his anger but we don't
get any more information about why he's
there or what he points out as how he
ended up there he didn't go there on
purpose she asked him a question about
what is it about society that
disappoints you so much and we
understand a little bit better about
what his major problem is with society
at large he goes into this monologue
that we find out has just imagined later
but he rants about late capitalism
social media retail sedation the way
that we buy things and consume things
because we need to feel better we create
these online persona that make us the
person that we would like to be rather
than the person that we are and we
basically learned that he packs into
people's lives with good intentions like
he wants to right wrong and we saw that
with Ron and pornography right he tells
Christa that it's painful not to pretend
and she says that when you hide your
delusions come back we don't learn any
more about these delusions but we get
hints around the fact that him being
paranoid that people are following him
and that we see these guys kind of like
men and black type guys and suits that
seem to be hanging around when he goes
places we meet Angela's boyfriend who
seems like a real tool for the most part
one of my favorite lines of the pilot is
him saying I'm okay with it being
awkward to ollie but really it's just
more of the same he's just really
developing the character we get an
introduction to eat Corp which is the
company that Elliott despises he calls
an evil Corp and we noticed several
times that he actually has reprogrammed
his brain to hear evil Corp even when
other people say the name or we see
commercials and things we meet different
characters Terry Colby the CTO of evil
Corp tyrell wellick who is a underling
of Terry Colby's but we get that he
tries to connect with Elliott on some
levels on a tech playing field I guess
you could say and he says the techies as
he walks away after they talk he says
bon soir Elliott and this kind of comes
back up again later back at his
apartment we find out he has a fish and
it's very important to him we see him
having a crying fit and he says I hate
when I can't hold in my loneliness and
we get an idea that this has been
popping up more often late
we also see that he has a tendency to
want to control the uncontrollable I
would say with his morphine and suboxone
like he explains to us his
well-thought-out plan of how he avoids
becoming addicted but anybody can guess
that that's not something that is done
through logic addiction is addiction
because it takes a hold of people so we
get that there we meet Shayla who lives
across the hall she's this connection
for the suboxone he ends up taking drugs
with her and he tells us never make
decisions when you're on morphine
they're what they're in bed after their
Molly excursion and he gets a
notification on his phone and we find
out that he's trying to hack Krista's
boyfriend he eventually is able to do
that it's a little bit of social
engineering and after the fact he gets
the call from Angela at 3:00 a.m. and
there's a big evil core pack that's
going down in dramatic fashion he stops
the hack along with Gideon who flies him
to the server farm but he leaves an
infected server there after he wonders
why he wants to leave it this is a
critical part of the development of the
story and since we don't know much about
Elliot yet we don't really know why he
has this but it definitely comes back
again later we see a rare bonding moment
with Gideon on the plane and there's an
awkwardness where Gideon comes out to
him but we see Elliot make an effort and
he's able to kind of promise getting in
that he'll take care of things on the
train ride home we meet mr. robot
officially for the first time he
approaches him tells him to follow him
he explains that if he didn't delete it
then he should come along if he did
delete it then it's over and they go to
Coney Island visit an arcade he finds
out that the DDoS attack was a test he
sees others there but he doesn't talk to
anyone and he just learns a little bit
about what's going on from mr. robot he
leaves her thinking he's crazy and he
goes through his mind ass
yes if we saw what he saw and he's kind
of trying to say it's not a delusion I
had seen this this is a fact so he's
sort of just trying to reinforce what's
reality and what's not when he gets home
Angela's waiting for him and she wants
to watch Back to the Future 2 with him
because it's his favorite movie but when
they go inside shale is still there he
asked her to leave and then he searches
for eff society but he doesn't find
anything after that he goes back to
Coney Island to tell them that he's
gonna turn them in and there we get the
payoff of mr. robot explaining their
plan Eliot is sort of drawn in by this
idea of erasing everyone's dead he's not
a hundred percent on board though he
goes into the meeting and Terry Colby he
is totally disrespectful and a giant
dick to Angela and that convinces him to
give up the altered DAT file he knows
that this is going to implicate Colby
and we get a jump in time afterwards
we're three weeks pass at that time he
finally gets to the bottom of who
Krista's boyfriend is finds out he's
married and he makes him break up with
her at that time we see it Krista's
urging he goes and he talks to Angela
and they have a moment but it gets
interrupted but when news of Terry
Colby's arrest happens on TV he seems
pretty excited overall about this whole
thing as he's watching the news at Times
Square he says this is happening this is
happening but just as that goes down we
meet this new character his name is mr.
Sutherland
and he tells Elliot to get in the car
and they take him back to evil Corp
there's a bit of a cliffhanger here
where we see Tyrell again and he says
bonsoir Elliot and we're left not
knowing exactly why or what's going on
at the end of the episode we just know
that someone picked him up off the
street after Terry Colby got fired and
now he's in a place where he doesn't
really like to be so I mentioned there
were a couple of weak points or things
that raised red flags for some people in
episode 1
from what I understand as in this was
totally technically over my head so it
didn't stand out for me the show took
certain liberties in the way Elliott
gathered information on Ron the coffee
shop owner in the beginning in other
words people who were really tech savvy
have been gravitating towards this show
and they had like issues with it
apparently Sam SML mentioned that he
wished he hadn't done it that way and
the show beyond this puts a lot of
effort into making what Elliott and the
others do on their computers technically
sound they have a guy who is a technical
director who puts a lot of time in
setting things up that you know down to
the computer screens and everything else
we see and I know from following the
fandom that people are pretty impressed
with the way that they do things after
this one event the other thing is that
mr. robots plan to erase debt as a way
of just redistributing wealth I mean
whether you understand economics or not
this might strike you as a way to simple
solution to a very complex and
entrenched problem and you'd be right
but you have to go as is you said to let
it go at this point without spoiling
anything I'll just say that don't get
hung up on this because we'll learn more
about the motivations and viability of
the F Society ideas as things progress
the good news here is that these are
pretty much small potatoes particularly
in a pilot episode of a brand new series
and just stick with it and the rewards
will come so one of the major things
here is is that you know Elliott's a
likable character but we can't trust him
because you can't trust himself and even
though he does this hacktivism I guess
you would call it where he does good
things with this hacking he also hacks
his friends to discover secrets about
them partly because he just wants to
know but more so because he has
difficulty talking to them you know what
I'm saying like he knows things that he
shouldn't actually know about people and
he finds it because he's talented but
it's also a way for him to avoid just
learning people skills so it's not
necessarily like you know he's not a
perfect
hero in that way he obviously has
something in his past that has landed
him in Krista's office so you can
imagine that she's gonna be an important
character and there is some delusion
involved that we hear from from her so
you know some things that we see that he
sees or we see through his eyes I guess
you could say may not be real so I think
that you know even though he's a flawed
character he's clearly the hero of the
story and I think they do a good job
here of bringing us into how human he
actually is how complex and damaged his
psychology is and give us an idea that
he's not really a bad person what he is
is a lonely person and we saw that in
the scene where he's crying in his room
we see that he also abuses drugs and you
know like I said that the loosen ations
and things are real on some level his
father as he mentioned was the only
person he could ever talk to that guy
died it was leukemia from exposure to
workplace radiation we saw in a quick
scene that his mother was abusive he's
he's distant he's not naturally able to
communicate with people in small talk
and things like that
he sort of wears the hoodie with the
zipped up kind of security blanket thing
going on and it you know it says a lot
about the actor he won the Emmy last
year for Best Actor and a Drama Series
and he's definitely really good he
brings this character to life and it's
an interesting thing to watch so that's
pretty much it for the first episode
make sure you leave any questions you
have in the comments I'll put some links
to where you can watch it and things
like that in the description there's
only two seasons at this point so
there's plenty of time to catch up
before the show airs next month please
like this video if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel and set your
notifications if you're into mr. robot
or any of the other shows I do I'm gonna
go through this season at the very least
I've already got episode recaps for
season 2
because I did him last year but I'm a
relook at some of those and I am
planning to go through the companion
book next as well that goes along with
season 2 though so I want to get through
this first so yeah lots of mr. robot
stuff this season if you followed me for
other shows you know how I do it I'll do
several videos each week when it's in
season so make sure you check back if
you like twin peaks' check my patreon
account I got a twin peaks' book
giveaway going on there
and I will be looking for future ideas
on that show and other things so just
read all about it there so that's it for
now thanks for watching guys I will talk
to you soon